parce que nos villes se transforment
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
iprema votre partenaire pour un
développement
[Musique]
durable bonjour et bienvenue dans
équilibre le magazine de l'environnement
et du développement durable au sommaire
de ce numéro l'eau que nous buvons à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline est produite
pas très loin d'ici à l'usine d'eau
potable de louvienne nous nous y sommes
rendus pour découvrir les différentes
étapes de traitement pour que l'eau
devienne propre à la consommation on
connaît tous les différentes poubelles
qui nous permettent de trier nos déchets
ce tri est encore affiné dans des
centres celui situé à rambouiller nous a
ouvert ses portes deux passionnés
cantinois ont recensé les espèces de
champignons urbains présent sur la
commune de Montini le Bretonneux nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de l'un
d'entre eux mais tout d'abord nous
sommes en pleine période de fête nos
maison nos rues sont décorées parfois
nous utilisons des guirlandes lumineuses
cela peut vite faire monter nos factures
d'électricité pour y remédier plusieurs
communes cinqutinoises ont décidé
d'acheter des décorations en lide avec
Elodie moine nous sommes allés vérifier
ce que change vraiment ces petites
ampoules on a beau les scruter quand on
n'est pas connaisseur difficile de faire
la différence entre les ampoules
normales et les leds et pourtant ces
petites diodes électroluminescentes sont
bien là si elles sont encore cher les
ledes permettent d'éclairer jusqu'à 40
M00 he elles s'allument instantanément
et supporte les allumages répétés c'est
la technologie qui est bien meilleure
une lampe incandescence et un filament
qui chauffe c'est en gros 95 % de perte
en chaleur 5 % de rendement la LED c'est
optimisé pour éclairer c'est de la
microélectronique et c'est le rendement
de 95 15 % avec très peu de perte en
chaleur j'ai l'exemple d'une commune qui
a remplacé tout son parc et qui est
passé de 6000 kWh à 700 kWh soit des
économies de 88 % si on fait le calcul
de consommation d'énergie plusieurs
communes cinquantinoises l'ont bien
compris et renouvell depuis plusieurs
années leur parc c'est le cas de trappe
où le changement de décoration a
commencé en 2004 les guirlandes Aled il
consomme 4 W uniquement sur tronçon sur
chaque tronçon tandis que les les
ampoules normales cons som 14 W par
tronçon c'est quasiment quatre fois
moins que que les anciennes ampoules
aujourd'hui le parc lumière de la
commune est à 80 % en LED trappe espère
passer à 100 % d'ici 2016 voire 2015 un
moyen de rester dans l'esprit de Noël
sans que la facture soit salée trappe y
consacre 15000 € par
an beaucoup d'entre nous boivent de
l'eau du robinet mais avant qu'elle
arrive dans nos tuyau elle est traitée
dans une usine à Louvecienne qui la rend
potable cette usine produit 21 millions
de mè CUB d'eau par an et elle dessert
21 communes nous avons suivi raphaë Pia
le responsable des travaux à la cvesque
le service des EAU de Versailles et de
saclou un reportage avec William
l ici on est au sommet de l'usine 2 donc
de l'autre côté on voit l'usine 1
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les deux
usines fonctionnent en série c'estàdire
que l'eau va venir être traité dans unee
des usines ensuite passer sur la
deuxième usine voilà c'est pas deux
usines en parallèle qui traitent chacun
l'eau de leur côté c'est vraiment de
usines qui fonctionnent
[Musique]
ensemble on a des forages 11 forages sur
ce champ captant qui viennent prendre
l'eau dans la nappe et qui vont venir la
renvoyer au travers d'une grosse station
de pompage dans ses bassins
donc c'est là où vous voyez l'eau
arriver sur les dans les bassins au
niveau des petites chutes d'eau qu'on
voit aux angles des différents
bassins donc ici on a au total 18 hectar
de bassin pour une contenance utile
totale de 500000 M C qui nous permet
d'avoir une autonomie entre 5 et 7 jours
on n pas commencé le traitement on est
sur de l'eau brute donc de l'eau qui
provient des forages qui n'a pas encore
été
traité
[Musique]
donc ici on est vraiment sur la première
étape du traitement donc on a de l'eau
qui provient directement des bassins et
la première étape c'est ce qu'on appelle
le microamisage pour l'illustrer le plus
simple c'est d'imaginer un grand tambour
de machine à laver don les par serait
fait avec des mailles très très fines
voilà s'il y a des feuilles mortes' a
des choses comme ça qui pourrait trouver
dans l'eau c'est éliminé dès cette
première étape
[Musique]
là on parle d'ozone c'est souvent connu
comme un polluant effectivement c'est un
polluant atmosphérique donc il faut
savoir que le gaz au zone qu'on utilise
on le rejette pas dans l'atmosphère le
résiduel on le rejette pas on a des
destructeurs d'ozone qui sont là pour
éliminer
l'ozone l'ozone c'est un désinfectant
c'est un très fort oxydant qui vient en
fait détruire les molécules organiques
et assurer la désinfection de l'eau donc
c'est vraiment un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désinfectant ici nous avons les filtres
nitrificateurs qui permettent en fait
d'éliminer l'ammoniaque qui peut être
contenu dans l'eau et qui assure en plus
en complément un rôle de filtration pour
retenir les particules prisantes dans
l'eau
[Musique]
donc là ce que je vais vous montrer
c'est l'étape de postzonation sur lequel
se fait le gros de la désinfection au
sein de l'usine donc le principe c'est
qu'on a de l'air chargé en ozone qu'on
va venir injecter dans l'eau sous de
fine bulle et en fait le contact entre C
a auzoné et l'eau va permettre la
[Musique]
désinfection le CAG trois rôles d'abord
finira d'éliminer si jamais il y avait
des résiduels d'ozone dans l'eau le CAG
l'arrête complètement ça joue un rôle
sur la rétention des tout ce qui est
pesticides et
puis voilà pour tout ce qui va être goût
de l'eau ça joue un rôle c'estd que ça
permet de d'atténuer de retenir
certaines molécules qui peuvent donner
des des goûts à
[Musique]
l'eau voilà donc ici c'est l'étape de
chloration dans lequel on vient en fait
injecter du chlore l'origine du clur
gazux dans l'eau potable c'est vraiment
la dernière étape de traitement
le chlore son utilité c'est que c'est un
désinfectant qui reste actif dans le
temps et qui permet que l'eau tout au
long de son trajet travers du réseau
pour aller jusque jusquau consommateur
reste bien désinfecté
[Musique]
potableci par exemple vous avez les
conduites qui vont venir envoyer l'au
trité qui est stocké dans les ailes de
l'usine vers les les citernes qui gère
le départ vers le
[Musique]
réseau plusieurs de nos déchets ménagers
peuvent être valoriser pour cela il faut
l'étrier la première étape c'est nous
les citoyens qui la faisons mais avant
qu'il redeviennent des objets ou qu'il
soi transformés en textile il passe par
des centres de tri celui de rambouillé
concerne les emballages il nous a ouvert
ses portes un reportage réalisé avec
William
l bouteille en plastique pot de peinture
ou encore brique de lait voici quelques
exemples de déchets qui arrivent ici ils
vont être triés avec minuci pour pouvoir
être recyclés première étape la cabine
de préterie une des deux sélections
manuelles du circuit de triage on enlève
ce qu'on appelle ici les grosses erreurs
de tri tout ce qui est mis en sac
poubelle fermé est considéré comme un
refus parce que les les opérateurs de
tri ne sont pas censés savoir ce qu'il y
a dedans et ne les ouvrent pas parce que
ça peut être dangereux sur l'année 2013
18,5 % des déchets ont été
refusés après ce premier tri quatre
étapes se font mécaniquement le Tromel
un cylindre qui tourne comme une machine
à laver grâce à ce système les
contenants tels que les BO de conserve
les bouteilles sont séparés des corps
plat que sont les papiers journaux et
magazines autre appareil le séparateur
optique le rayon optique analyse le taux
de transparence de l'objet en fonction
du résultat les déchets sont orientés
vers le bon
tapis en deux étapes une première étape
qui va séparer les plastiques et une
deuxè étape qui va séparer les Bries
des de l'aluminium grâce à ces machines
la qualité de tri approche les 98 % une
fois ces trois étapes mécaniques
direction la cabine de tri deuxème
manipulation manuelle et dernière étape
au total ce centre de trip traite 15000
tonnes annuelles de déchets par an le
nombre de de kilos augmente légèrement
il a une tendance actuellement à stagner
mais il stagne non pas du fait que les
gens trient moins il stagnent parce que
la consommation baisse et que
effectivement en période de crise il y a
moins de déchets qu'auparavant une fois
triés les déchets sont compactés pour
être amenés dans des centre de
valorisation et ainsi avoir une deuxième
vie et maintenant direction Montini où
deux passionnés ont recensé toutes les
espèces de champignons que l'on peut
trouver au bord de nos routes et le
nombre découvert pourrait facilement
vous surprendre un reportage réalisé
avec Anthony
Resche bolet lactter elvel et tant
d'autres près de 160 espèces sur une
surface allant du quartier des prê à
celui de la Sourderie
il a fallu 4 ans à Gilbert Daven et
Étienne Varnet pour les recenser l'odeur
là le le le terrain est est intéressant
parce qu' on a je dirais des arbres des
SAS des boulots des pains
qui qui comment dire auquel s'associe un
certain nombre de de champignons ces
champignons j' dirais participe à la
croissance de l'arbre ils sont en
symbiose avec avec l'arbre et les arbres
pousse je dirais deux fois plus vite
s'ils sont associés à ces à ces à ces
champignons un clitosible cette étude de
21 pages a été publiée dans le Bulletin
trimestriel de l'Association des
naturalistes des Yvelines un travail
réalisé par des passionnés c'est un
hobby effectivement nous sommes amateurs
les mycologues en en France en général
sont amateurs il y a très peu de de
professionnels il y en a il y en a
quelques-uns dans dans les universités
l' Université de Lille il y a de deux
mychologues mais je dirais c'est
vraiment un cas en général la mychologie
est une affaire d'amateur éclairéonna
pas mais attention parce qu'ils sont
proches de la route ces champignons
aussi beaux soit-ils ne peuvent
malheureusement pas être
mangés avant de nous quitter notez ces
rendez-vous tous les dimanches la ferme
pédagogique de la base de loisir de
Saint-Quentin vous propose des ateliers
pour découvrir les gestes à apporter aux
animaux en cette période d'hiver voilà
équilibre c'est terminé je vous retrouve
le mois prochain d'ici là passez de très
bonnes fêtes et surtout n'oubliez pas
faites un geste pour
[Musique]
l'environnement